that me yeah all quiet so far I've gotta
feel that's about to change I'm glad I
took a chance on this its collaboration
of ours keep on doing what you're doing
and the rest of Gotham will start to see
you like I do a hero
the enemies were facing the things all
have to do Gotham might not want to see
we have bigger things to worry about
right now your security has been
compromised I've got patrols on every
door you better check on them I'd keep
that holstered if I were you what's she
doing here she was part of that robbery
at the mayor's office really you're
gonna drag out that dead horse I think
she's mending her ways oh he's right
lieutenant I don't do the bad things
anymore unless it's on request this
better not come back to bite me off a
patrol come in that um incident in the
bar dad is its own kind of cage I can't
stand being in it not that I needed your
help or anything but you had my back I
thought I'd repay the favor you know
like you scratch my back I cut some
people up you don't owe me anything
those scum had it coming and they say
chivalry is dead none of my men on the
ground are responding enough waiting
we're going in alpha do you read now
aren't you glad I'm here I give a better
shot than my SWAT team of getting in
there quietly
we are seriously underfunded at the GCPD
sounds like a vote for dead lieutenant